hello and welcome to this video which is
an orangutan one before
yes p9 1 8 is my opponent ok
yeah against this ie 5 is definitely
best it's really not much to argue there
ok maybe he will take a 95 he doesn't
okay yeah here I was thinking that just
taking should be quite fine looks like a
very convenient structure it's got some
some issues
I wonder if echo Bishop f5 here we
should have 5 Bishop to d3
it's not very convincing actually if I
go Queen to f6
is that better maybe start with this
yeah maybe it's it the temple the temple
once III Bishop d3 I will take one c3
was check I guess yeah okay this this
was this was certainly possible I can
take on c3 actually due to the pinning
situation on the e farm Y can take on d4
pawn takes okay take him I cannot do
that take on g3 H takes and h7 is
hanging it still looks like a good way
to play sorry Bishop f5 I was thinking
Bishop d3 93 H takes Queen takes d4
should win should win a pawn
no the rook is hanging with the tempo
with chicken so what is he going to play
now look do you want maybe
maybe castling long was the nose can
still take one d3 anyway oh I didn't see
that one coming
I can't take you - is it set there's no
reason not to huh I mean the rook on d3
does not have a fantastic fantastic
square or anything I can take only three
here actually
the queen is unprotected
[Music]
yeah that is some winning the house
actually
it's made TechSmith yeah I don't do it
we rematch I want to do a quick look
first there's always a little bit sad in
a way but otherwise you don't get the
format straight yeah on the game per
video yeah here I was thinking you
should take on f6 and I felt this is
probably a roughly equal position he
gets the bishop back probably back to
the 8th and then something like that
should be roughly equal I was thinking
more in 3 I don't know then maybe black
is a bit more a bit more comfortable due
to the development but it's nothing
special Queen f6 yeah but after that I'm
definitely for choice the white
structure is a bit too awful d6 and
Queen to f6 good moves and now I think
Knight takes c3 also was possible but I
wasn't entirely sure about it just
looked a little bit odd it's probably
not I was more concise thinking I was
should take Bishop a5 I did not see what
the engine recommends and I was seeing
this and it wasn't clear to me because
my knight is running around and yeah and
and it's this felt like a simple
solution I'm threatening Queen g3 and
indirectly always Queen takes d4 after
the knight has moved so I'm winning with
this lineup winning upon I was briefly
thinking about this but yeah I can take
one d3 as a simple way to do it yeah and
hook to you one I'm basically just a
pawn up for not much one yeah not much I
mean I'm actually for choice position
wise okay I took him and now Ruby three
years
everything yeah one before is basically
not that great but white is probably
with best play still equal you should
call you five though I think this is
more powerful than other options yeah
thanks a lot for watching